i hope i never have to play for anybody
else other than the seattle seahawks the
reality is in professional sports things
change you know um and times change and
and
you know coaches and people and
everything else and one of my dreams is
to have always played for the same team
for a really long time and
my whole entire career and
that is true you know excellence that is
true
that's a true legacy
that's russell wilson from the pft pm
podcast december of 2017. he said in
that same interview he wants to play
until he's 45. but here's the dilemma
his contract runs through 2019. he was
on the tonight show last month talking
about the great potential of being the
highest paid player in league history as
it turns out the seahawks and russell
wilson have been negotiating a contract
and he has supplied them with an april
15 deadline to get it done there's no or
else in terms of a holdout because i'm
told he will not hold out under any set
of circumstances he'll be there for all
voluntary and involuntary
offseason regular season pre-season
activities but peter
how does he get that contract he wants
if he really doesn't have any immediate
leverage by way of withholding services
your thoughts on what russell wilson is
trying to do
you know i've always thought the one
thing that mark rogers the agent for
russell wilson brought to the table
that's a little bit different than most
agents
in football
understand mark rogers is almost
exclusively a baseball agent
and over the years when i have had
conversations with him he has never been
afraid
of playing year to year especially when
you've got a durable guy like russell
wilson why would you be afraid you saw
what happened with kirk cousins kirk
cousins made over a five-year period
gigan you know including the current
three years a gigantic money and every
dime was guaranteed you know obviously
the first two times because they were
you know in tags but now
the three years is totally guaranteed
for him and i believe that if
uh russell wilson has to play under the
franchise tag maybe one year or two it
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
but i also believe that the seattle
seahawks you know understand
that if they sign him long term at let's
just say 33 or whatever the number is
34. somebody obviously is going to
hopscotch that but they will spend less
money
if they sign him at an average number of
about 33 or 34 than they would if they
waited a couple of years to you know
sign them year to year and then
uh you know sign him for the long term
the one other point i would make mike is
i don't think john schneider the gm of
the seahawks can be cowed into anything
you know he has gotten beat up
time and again
richard sherman you know uh earl thomas
cam chancellor
he's he has really been beat up locally
in seattle over the last few years and
what has he said
nothing
absolutely nothing he just simply views
that as the cost of doing business he
doesn't whine he doesn't complain so
i mean as far as an april 15 deadline
for russell wilson i've not talked to
john schneider about it so i don't know
but john schneider probably slept pretty
soundly last night is all i can say
you know my theory on all of this is
that russell wilson does want to go year
to year when we do the calculation the
numbers get huge very quickly in 2020
the franchise tender based on his cap
number this year is 30.34 million the
next year 36-4 if they tag him for a
third time it spikes to
52.43 million if you add up the next
four years of what he would make if he
goes year to year it averages 34 million
a year so i think he wants to go year to
year and he's giving them a window to
try to change his mind that's his
leverage his leverage is hey this is
your opportunity to do the thing you
want me to do you want me to sign a
long-term deal you got until april 15 to
put an offer on the table that i'll sign
otherwise i'm going year to year and
we'll see if and when i hit the open
market and if i do you'll have a chance
to try to sign me along with anyone else
who may want to sign me here's the other
point too peter and this is where i
think mark rogers is going and you hit
the nail on the head he's got one
current nfl client and that's russell
wilson so he doesn't have all these
other relationships and issues and
tentacles to worry about he can focus on
getting the best deal for russell wilson
i think wilson is going to try to get
what others have tried and failed to get
cousins tried to get it darrell rivas
tried to get it maybe others have tried
to get it
wilson i think is going to try to get a
percentage of the salary cap as
guaranteed compensation so as the market
changes as the cap spikes with a new cba
new tv deals gambling money
legalized gambling revenues that flow to
the nfl as that pie grows and grows and
grows and the cap goes up and up and up
he's going to want to have that
protection so he always gets 17 18 19
percent of the cap wherever that number
goes i think that's what they want and
the question is will the seahawks give
it to him
it's a great question
if i were the seahawks in that
particular case at least for now i think
i'd rather go year to year but i do
think that eventually the only way that
makes sense for the seahawks is trying
to make a deal long term with a guy who
is as good a human being and a
representative of your team as you're
going to find
um mike i i would not be remotely
surprised at what you're saying because
mark rogers is a very very smart guy i
wouldn't be surprised at that at all
um and you know what i think he's right
i really think he's right if you believe
that you are the best
uh
you know the best option for the
seahawks and the seahawks know it why
wouldn't they do that and say okay we'll
adjust your salary every year to be 18
percent of the cap or pick 17 whatever
the number is
and think about this i mean they're
looking at 30.34 million devoted
exclusively to russell wilson next year
2020 under the cap and you can't play
any games reducing the cap number in the
short term unless you sign into a
long-term deal he's got the leverage the
next year 36-4 same thing you're stuck
with that and we're only three years
away from the seahawks facing the
dilemma peter of having to pay the guy
52.43 million for one year i don't know
where the salary cap's going to be then
but that that is beyond unprecedented to
think of that kind of a cap number for
one player but that's that's his
leverage his leverage is you change my
mind with a long-term contract by april
15 or i'm going to continue this path of
kirk cousins because i ain't kirk
cousins kirk cousins is a middle of the
pack guy that made 128 million over five
years i'm one of the top three or four
or five quarterbacks in the league and
i'm going to ride this thing out one
year at a time and either you or
somebody else is going to make me the
highest paid player in league history
maybe buy a wide margin
i
i just think that
at some point some way this is going to
get done
just because i know the affection the
seahawks have for wilson i know the
affection he has for them
and
uh mark rogers is not an incendiary
device
he isn't he's a reasonable guy
and you know it's easy for me to say
that i'm not negotiating with them but i
i believe that this thing is going to
get done because it makes too much sense
to not get done
you know the best thing they did the
last time around they being mark rogers
and russell wilson
he had just finished his third year
and because he wasn't a first round pick
the seahawks had to deal with it because
they were going to get into the
franchise tag dance if they didn't it
was only a four-year extension you know
we've seen guys like aaron rodgers do
these six years ago he did a six-year
contract back in 2013 he did another
five-year deal a four-year extension
when you are only in the league three
years that sets you up to really put
pressure on a team while you're entering
your prime i mean russell wilson said he
wants to play until he's 45 we're seeing
more and more of these guys play very
well into their late 30s tom brady's
playing very well at 41. he's still got
a lot of prime years to earn and russell
wilson is moving into
a formula if he chooses to follow it
year to year that could unlock the kind
of wealth that we've never seen an nfl
player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports